there was stuff like that like that
killed at the table but for whatever
reason we put it in front of the
audience people were baffled like I had
this one I remember Larry David hosted I
don't know if we talked about Larry
David host it was one of my favorite
sketches
um he played a guy that that came up
with the California Raisins and he
invited Keenan invited Keenan and Leslie
over to pitch the California Raisins so
he was like yeah they're raising they
sing Motown songs like this is kind of
racist but how is it racist and uh and
we had like all these drawings of like
the California Raisins as pimps and
playing basketball and and the
audience saw it and they were just like
absolutely not